the daily callers andrew kerr reported
that andrew cuomo was
under counting nursing home deaths in
may of last
year last year but the media ignored
that story
instead they spent all their energy
slobbering
over andrew cuomo been commended
for your clear and your calm leadership
people from
all over the country in the world have
tuned into your press conferences your
statewide approval rating
a career high 84 percent
you came in second only to president
obama as the most
trusted democratic leader in america
think about something grander bigger
presidential he is no holds barred he
says
exactly what he's thinking as you know
that's his style you can see that and
you ask the tough questions i tell you
that much as well they found
that the cuomo brothers you and your
brother chris
tied as the most desirable men in new
york in the movie of this when it's
finally made
who do you want to have play you get
about running for president tell the
audience
governor cuomo i think is is one of the
heroes
on the front line i think he's doing a
hell of a job i think he has been the
lead horse here
real leadership of the kind the
president of the united states
should have provided this has been a
remarkable show of leadership by
governor cuomo in recent days
he's providing hope but not false hope
oh they're so craven such little
tattletail suck-ups
they're rude to waiters but they suck up
to those above them it's unbelievable
but now they've changed their view
they're saying that andrew cuomo must
resign not because he killed people
but because he said naughty things to
women for democrats that is a convenient
strategy
yesterday for example michigan governor
gretchen whitner whitmer who may be
actually the worst governor in america
was asked about nursing home deaths in
her state
what did she want to talk about andrew
cuomo's sexual harassment
i think the allegations here are very
serious and need to be taken seriously
and i do think that a an impartial
thorough independent investigation is
merited and appropriate i think that
these are serious allegations
and um if if accurate and true
and i think we have to take action
how can she be governor of a state it's
unbelievable
seth barron edits the american mind he
joins us tonight
um seth you've been you've been pretty
on this cuomo story for a very long time
how did you feel as you watched the
anointed priesthood of the american
media
slobber on this guy well as long as they
were wearing their trump goggles
it was easy to see uh andrew cuomo as
the love gov
but then in the cold light of fifteen
thousand nursing home deaths and a
series of
awkward come-ons uh you know the love
gov
seems a little gruesome um yeah it's
been
a amusing trip for anyone who's been
watching
yeah as you pointed out the daily caller
said back in may
that there they were under counting the
deaths uh
you know andrew cuomo bungled the entire
response but because everyone was so
fixated on painting trump as the real
enemy
they just had to laud cuomo as this
you know this new great leader uh so
what's happened now is
is not really surprising everybody's
just come back to earth and woken up and
you know
seeing what's really in front of their
eyes let me ask you
since we're all being now we can all be
totally honest with andrew cuomo and i
don't mean this in a mean way
but i just have to say it he talks like
he's in good fellas i mean he literally
looks like he's doing some sort of mafia
impersonation does anybody ever say that
out loud or you're not allowed to say
that
you're not allowed to say that i mean
listen his father mario cuomo
used to say that the mafia doesn't exist
uh but andrew grumma has been talking
this way since he was in his early 20s
with his weird repetitions and his odd
phrases
so it's nothing new god i feel like
we're in front of a social club in
brooklyn i'm not against it it's kind of
old-fashioned and interesting but it's
so noticeable it's like no one ever says
it
anyway seth it's great to see you
tonight thank you for coming on
thanks tucker